♪
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR
FINAL EXAM WHEN YOU FIND OUT
WHO AT FOX IS REALLY
FOLLOWING THE NEWS AND WHO
IS JUST READING A
TELEPROMPTER.
NOT REPORTERS HAVE
TELEPROMPTERS ONLY I DO.
LAUREN BLANCHARD UNSEATED
THE GREAT ED HENRY LAST WEEK
UNCEREMONIOUSLY.
ANOTHER CORRESPONDENT AND
CONTESTANT ON THIS SHOW
PETER DOOCY.
WELCOME BACK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: AND WELCOME BACK
TO YOU OUR DEFENDING
CHAMPION.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Tucker: HE NO THE RULES
AND FOR THOSE AT HOME MAY
NOT.
FIRST ONE BUZZED IN GETS TO
AFFIDAVIT YOU HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL I FINISH ASKING IT.
EACH QUESTION WORTH ONE
POINT.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG WE
SUBTRACT A POINT.
WE DON'T WANT TO BUT WE HAVE
TO.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
READY?
>> IF I'M NOT READY, CAN I
HAVE A FEW MINUTES?
>> Tucker: NO, YOU CAN'T
PHONE A FRIEND EITHER.
FIRST QUESTION, THIS WEEK
SEX IN THE CITY ACTRESS
CYNTHIA NIXON THREW HER HAT
TO RUN FOR WHICH NATIONAL
OFFICE?
PETER DOOCY?
>> THAT WOULD BE THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK.
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE A
GOVERNOR, ARE YOU SURE?
>> ONE OF THE CUOMOS FOR
NOW.
>> Tucker: ROLL TAPE.
IS IT GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK?
>> THE ACTRESS IS HOPING TO
ADD NEW YORK GOVERNOR TO HER
RESUME.
>> TOGETHER WE CAN WIN THIS
FIGHT.
ON MONDAY, THE TONY EMMY AND
GRAMMY WINNER ANNOUNCED SHE
WOULD CHALLENGE THE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT ANDREW
CUOMO.
>> TONY, EMMY AND GRAMMY.
>> Tucker: PETER DOOCY
FOLLOWING THE NEWS OUT OF
NEW YORK.
ALL RIGHT.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: EVEN DEMOCRATS
GETTING FED UP WITH THE
MAINSTREAM PRESS COVERAGE OF
RUSSIA WHICH IS NONSTOP.
WHICH FILMMAKER JUST
COMPLAINED THAT THE RUSSIA
STORY IS, QUOTE:  A SHINY
KEY TO DISTRACT US?
LAUREN BLANCHARD?
>> THAT IS MICHAEL MOORE.
>> Tucker: MICHAEL MOORE
SAYS SOMETHING TRUE.
IS IT MICHAEL MOORE?
>> EVEN SOME OF THE NETWORKS
THAT WE WATCH WERE, YOU
KNOW, RUSSIA, TURN THE
CHANNEL, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
AND.
>> TALKING ABOUT STORMY
DANIELS.
>> ALL THE SHINY KEYS TO
DISTRACT US.
THAT'S WHAT GOES ON IN THE
MEDIA.
>> Tucker: OH SAYS MICHAEL
MOORE SPEAKING OF RUSSIA A
STALEMATE BETWEEN YOU.
ONE EACH.
>> IS HE PROMOTING
SOMETHING?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
>> IS HE ALWAYS PROMOTING.
>> Tucker: EVEN A FILMMAKER
TELLS THE TRUTH ONCE IN A
WHILE.
WHICH HOLLYWOOD ACTOR IS
BEING MOCKED MERCILESSLY
ONLINE FOR COVERING A THIRD
OF HIS PHYSICAL BEING WITH A
HUGE TATTOO.
>> PETER DOOCY?
>> IT'S BEN AFFLECK.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
YOU HE SEEMS
TOO SENSIBLE.
IS IT BEN AFFLECK.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT BEN AFFLECK.
GETTING TEASED ONLINE AFTER
A RECENT PHOTO REVEALED HE
HAS A GIANT BACK TATTOO.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN.
THIS TAKE A LOOK.
A GIANT PHOENIX THAT COVERS
HIS ENTIRE BACK.
CHECK OUT THIS NEW TATTOO
THAT HIS FRIEND MATT DAMON
JUST GOT.
IS HE SHOWING HIS SUPPORT
FOR --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: THAT'S GOOD.
I WAS IN THE JAPANESE MAFIA
THOUGH.
>> I WOULD BE CURIOUS WHAT'S
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN
A COUPLE YEARS.
>> Tucker: I'M SURE EVEN
BETTER.
QUESTION NUMBER FOUR AT
BUCKINGHAM PALACE THIS
WEEKEND 77-YEAR-OLD RICHARD
STARKEY WAS IGNITED BY.
IS HE BETTER KNOWN BY WHICH
STAGE NAME.
LAUREN BLANCHARD.
>> IS IT RINGO STARR OF THE
BEATLES?
>> Tucker: HERE WE GO.